[Música]
Qué es tan grande como un oso polar
engulle a su presa entera y nada a casi
65 kilómetros por hora no es un tiburón
ni una horca sino el atún rojo del
Atlántico es el atún más grande y
longevo de las 15 especies que hay el
atún rojo del Atlántico tiene una serie
única de adaptaciones que lo hace el
Depredador más dominante del océano
nace como una diminuta cría en el golfo
de México o el mar Mediterráneo no más
grande que una pestaña humana
en el primer año de vida desarrolla lo
que se denomina endotermia regional la
habilidad de regular su temperatura
corporal el atún del Atlántico obtiene
el oxígeno del agua fría del mar con sus
branquias este proceso enfría su sangre
luego el calor generado por el atún al
nadar y cazar calienta su sangre en la
mayoría de los peces este calor Se
perdería en el mar por las branquias
pero en el atún del Atlántico un
mecanismo llamado intercambiador de
contracorriente atrapa el calor la
sangre fría que fluye hacia los grandes
músculos nadadores pasa cerca de la
sangre caliente y deja a estos músculos
en una red especializada de vasos
sanguíneos llamada rete mirabile el
calor brinca hacia la sangre fría y se
queda en el cuerpo así el atún rojo es
una de las pocas especies de peces de
sangre caliente una gran ventaja en el
medio marítimo los animales de sangre
fría cuya temperatura corporal depende
por completo del ambiente se tan lentos
en aguas frías el atún rojo es capaz de
mantener calor y así tener una visión
más aguda puede procesar mejor la
información y nadar más rápido que su
presa
vive en aguas frías profundas y su
árticas gracias a su sangre caliente sus
poderosos músculos y su forma de torpedo
aerodinámico con aletas que se pliegan
en cavidades para reducir la resistencia
el atún rojo puede alcanzar velocidades
que otros animales no igualan alcanza
una velocidad máxima de casi 65
kilómetros por hora por lo que supera al
gran tiburón blanco o la horca incluso a
su cómoda velocidad de crucero pueden
cruzar el Atlántico en un par de meses
nadar esas distancias requiere de
muchísimo oxígeno pero el atún rojo está
bien adaptado para ello
entre más rápido nada más agua pasa por
sus branquias y más oxígeno puede
absorber del agua
esta necesidad de un flujo constante de
agua obliga a la tuna estar siempre en
movimiento implica también que el atún
rojo no puede succionar a su presa como
hace la mayoría de los peces en cambio
debe perseguir a su presa con la boca
abierta atrapan presas más pequeñas que
otros depredadores de su tamaño
calamares crustáceos y peces más
pequeños como el jurel
su habilidad para regular la temperatura
corporal no Solo lo hace un gran cazador
le da un campo de acción casi ilimitado
Tan pronto tiene fuerza para nadar
contra corriente el atún rojo Deja las
aguas tibias de su zona de desobe y pasa
su vida cazando por todo el Océano
Atlántico
los atunes del Golfo de México y del mar
Mediterráneo frecuentan las mismas zonas
de alimentación desde Brasil a Texas de
Islandia a senegal y más lejos aún pero
cuando llega la hora de reproducirse
como a los 10 años siempre regresan a su
mar de origen aquí grupos de machos y
hembras liberan millones de huevos y
esperma al agua migran de ida y vuelta
entre las zonas de alimento y desobe
cada año por el resto de sus vidas
el atún rojo del Atlántico puede vivir
más de 40 años sin dejar de crecer los
especímenes más grandes son decenas de
millones de veces más pesados que cuando
nacieron
el mismo gran tamaño que hace a este
atún indomable en el mar también lo hace
vulnerable a un Depredador particular
nosotros los humanos tienen una larga
historia de pescar al atún del Atlántico
que incluso está grabada en antiguas
monedas griegas pero en décadas
recientes la demanda se ha disparado
Pues el atún rojo se casa para sashimi
Sushi y filete de atún un solo pescado
llega a venderse en 10 mil dólares o más
lo que promueve la pesca ilegal o sobre
pesca pero si los esfuerzos de
conservación se redoblan y se cumple el
cupo permitido las poblaciones del atún
rojo pueden empezar a recuperarse
el mar está lleno de criaturitas raras y
peculiares ninguna es más peculiar que
el calamar Volador que puede alcanzar
velocidades de hasta 40 kilómetros por
hora cómo hacen estos animales marinos
para llegar hasta el cielo Explore las
increíbles capacidades de vuelo de los
calamares con este video